it was here on Saturday night that a
family Barbecue quickly became a tragedy
eleven-year-old Celine Thornton her
younger sister and their parents were
relaxing in their Garden when a gunman
started firing at them
local authorities believe that the
shooter was their elderly neighbor and
that there was a long-running dispute
the family's dad was doing Garden work
on the hedges separating the two
properties this exacerbated the
situation later the suspect took a
loaded 22 millimeter rifle three to four
shots were fired hitting the three
victims
celane was killed and both her parents
were injured her father Adrian is in a
critical condition with life-threatening
wounds their youngest daughter
eight-year-old Celeste managed to escape
the gunfire and raise the alarm a local
resident told us they saw Celeste
running to a neighbor's house she was
rushing to tell them her sister was dead
it's hard to imagine what the young girl
has seen and been through it's believed
this had been their home for four or
five years
located in Brittany in the west of
France the Thornton's home is in San
Ebola a tiny rural Hamlet near the city
of camper the small community has been
left devastated
[Music]
matild was in the same class as Solen
she told us how she heard the news
[Music]
it was Sunday I've been surfing and I
was in the car and my mum told me yes
it's terrible
the suspect is a Dutch national he shut
himself in his house with his wife after
the shooting military negotiators
persuaded him to give himself up so he
could be arrested
this is a close-knit community where
people know their neighbors they can't
believe one of them would kill a child
because of what appears to be a grudge
over a garden Becky Cottrell Sky News
San elbow in Brittany